[Music]
sometimes when people share an
environment they have a household
together they work in an office together
different people do different tasks or
not to keep the everything under control
to keep things tidy and to keep some
level of order going now what you often
see in this kind of shared space is
unconscious over claiming unconscious
over claiming is a phenomenon where
people unconsciously think that they are
contributing more than they actually are
to the total sum of work being done so
if you have a married couple and you say
how much of the total work are you doing
what it adds up to is more than a
hundred percent because both people will
unconsciously over claim how much
they're contributing same thing with
teams research shows that if you ask a
team who's doing what they will come up
with far more than a hundred percent
because everybody sees what they are
doing but they're not as aware of what
other people are doing so that makes
sense also people tend to do the things
that they value more that they think are
more important so they think their
contribution is very significant but to
other people well they might think
something else is more important so for
instance in my house I work on the
holiday cards and I think that's really
important my husband's very focused on
air conditioning repair he thinks that's
really important so if we're both
valuating what we're contributing to
kind of our team as a household we come
up with more than a hundred percent so
one thing that you want to remember if
you're thinking about may perhaps
conflict or how to manage a situation
where a lot of people are contributing
is you want to think about well how
might I be
undervaluing what someone else is doing
maybe I never load the dishwasher and so
I'm kind of just not even paying
attention to the fact that someone is
loading the dishwasher night after night
after night or taking out the trash or
feeding the dog or bringing you know
taking the newspapers to recycling or
whatever it is
it's very easy unfortunately to take for
granted what other people do especially
if they do it without complaint and then
over an overlook the contribution that
they're making and at the same time it's
easy to exaggerate in our minds what
we're doing how consistently we're doing
and how much we are contributing to the
overall total
of everything that needs to get done the
tragedy of the messy Commons is from a
phrase in law the tragedy of the Commons
and this is when people are sharing
something they're all making use of
something and because it's a shared
resource no one person feels that much
responsibility for maintaining it for
keeping it clean for keeping it
well-stocked or for doing the little
tasks that need to be done in order to
kind of keep the environment moving
along everybody's sort of like well it's
not really my problem it's not really my
job to clean out the fridge it's not
really my job to load the dishwasher and
hey everybody else is putting their
dirty dishes in the sink I think I will
too I don't see why I should put mine in
the dishwasher if everybody else is just
putting their dirty dishes in the sink
until when there are these areas that
are shared and no one one person has
responsibility they often become a
hotbed of anger and resentment and
controversy and passive-aggressive
signage what I think you need to do when
you have a messy comments like that is
to make it very clear what are the
expectations for the Commons and if
possible in my observation it's far
better to make it one person's job to
manage that than to try to share it it's
very hard to share tasks it's much
better if someone does a task someone's
responsible for it someone gets
recognized for it maybe somebody gets
paid for it as part of their duties and
they're in charge of that responsibility
because over and over and over again
I've seen the idea that everyone will
just do their part well people have
reasons for why they think that what
they're doing is appropriate or correct
and why they shouldn't have to do more
or anything different and those battles
will rage forever so you've got to be
careful of the tragedy of the messy
Commons and really try to come up with a
solution because it really can cause a
lot of friction and conflict among
people who really want to get along very
well
[Music]